The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today I'm starting a
new topic and that's always
the occasion for putting things
into perspective.
Keep in mind what we were trying
to do in the subject.
We were trying to introduce
several intellectual themes.
The first, and absolutely the
most important, is how do you
design a complex system?
We think that's very important
because there's absolutely no
way this department could exist
the way it does, making
things like that, hooking up
internets and so forth.
Those are truly complex
systems.
And if you didn't have an
organized way of thinking
about complexity, they're
hopeless.
So the kinds of things we're
interested to teach you about
are just hopeless if you can't
get a handle on complexity.
So that's by far the most
important thing that we've
been thinking about.
We've been interested in
modeling, and controlling
physical systems.
I hope you remember the way we
chased the robot around the
lab, and that was
the point there.
We've thought about augmenting
physical systems by adding
computation, I hope you've
got a feel for that.
And we're going to start today
thinking about how do you
build systems that are robust.
So just in review, so far--
you've already seen
most of this--
so far we've taught you about
abstraction, hierarchy, and
controlling complexity starting
primarily by thinking
about software engineering.
Because that's such a good
pedagogical place to start.
We introduced the idea of PCAP,
and that has continued
throughout the rest of the
subject, then we worried about
how do you control things.
We developed ways of modeling so
that you could predict the
outcome before you actually
built the system.
That's crucial.
You can't afford to build
prototypes for everything,
it's just not economical.
And so this was an exercise in
making models, figuring out
how behaviors relate to the
models, and trying to get the
design done in the modeling
stage rather than in the
prototyping stage, and
you built circuits.
This had to do with how you
augment a system with new
capabilities, either hardware
or software.
Today what I want to start to
think about is, how do you
with uncertainty?
And how do you deal with things
that are much more
complicated to plan?
So the things that we will do
in this segment are things
like mapping.
What if we gave you a maze--
you, the robot.
What if we gave the robot a maze
and didn't tell them the
structure of the maze?
How would it discover
the structure?
How would it make a map?
How would it localize?
What if you had a maze--
to make it simple, let's
say that I tell you
what the maze is.
But you wake up-- you're the
robot, you wake up, you have
no idea where you are.
What do you do?
How do you figure out
where you are?
That's a problem we
call localization.
And then planning.
What if you have a really
complicated objective?
What's the step-by-step
things that you
could do to get there?
Those are the kinds of things
we're going to do, and here's
a typical kind of problem.
Let's say that the robot starts
someplace, and say that
it has something in it
that lets it know
where it is, like GPS.
And it knows where
it wants to go.
Making a plan is not very
difficult, right?
I'm here and I want to
go there, connect
with a straight line.
And that's what I've
done here.
The problem is that unbeknownst
to the robot, that
path doesn't really work.
So on the first step, he thinks
he's going to go from
here to here in a
straight line.
The blue represents the path
that the robot would like to
take, but then on the first step
the sonars report that
they hit walls.
And those show up as the
black marks over here.
So already it can see that it's
not going to be able to
do what it wants to do.
So it starts to turn and it
finds even more places that
don't work.
Try again.
Notice that the plan now is,
well I don't know what's going
on here, but I certainly can't
go through there, so I'm going
to have to go around it.
Keep trying.
Notice the plan.
So he's always making a plan
that sort of make sense.
He's using for each plan the
information about the walls
that he's already figured out.
And now he's figured out,
well that didn't work.
So now back track, try
to get out of here.
AUDIENCE: Is he backtracking
right now?
Or is he--
PROFESSOR: Well, he's
going forward.
He's making a forward plan.
He's saying, OK now I know all
these walls are here, and I'm
way down in this corner, how
do I get on the other
side of that wall.
Well given the information that
I know, I'm going to have
to go around the known walls.
So my point of showing you
this is several fold.
First off it's uncertain.
You didn't know at the outset
just how bad the problem was.
So there's no way to kind of
pre-plan for all of this.
Secondly, it's a really
hard problem.
If you were to think about
structuring a program to solve
that problem, in a kind of
High School programming
sense-- if this happens
then do this, if this
happens then do this--
you would have a lot of
if statements, right?
That's just not the
way to do this.
So what we're going to learn to
do in this module is think
through much more complicated
plans.
We're going to be looking at the
kind of plans like shown
here that just are not practical
for, do this until
this happens, and then do this
until this happens, and then
while that's going
on, do this.
It's just not going to be
practical, that's the idea.
So the very first element, the
thing that we have to get on
top of first, is how to think
about uncertainty.
And there's a theory for that
and the theory is actually
trivial, the theory is actually
simple, except that
it's mind-boggling weird that
nobody can get their head
around it the first
time they see it.
It's called Probability
Theory.
As you'll see in a minute, the
rules are completely trivial.
You'll have no trouble
with the basic rules.
What you will have
trouble with--
unless you're a lot different
from most people--
the first time you see this
theory it's very hard to
imagine exactly what's
going on.
And it's extremely difficult
to have an intuition for
what's going on.
So the theory is going to give
us a framework then for
thinking about uncertainty.
In particular, uncertainty
sounds uncertain.
What we would like to do is make
precise statements about
uncertain situations.
Sounds contradictory, but we'll
do several examples in
lecture and then you'll
do a lot more
examples in the next week.
So that you learn exactly
what that means.
We would like to draw reliable
inferences from unreliable
observations.
OK, you have a lot of experience
with unreliable
observations, right?
The seminars don't tell you
the same thing each time.
That's what we'd like
to deal with.
We would like to be able to
take a bunch of different
individually, not all that
reliable observations, and
come up with a conclusion that's
a lot more reliable
than any particular
observation.
And when we're all done with
that what we'd like to do is
use this theory to help us
design robust systems.
Systems that are not fragile.
Systems that are not thrown off
track by having a small
feature that was not part of
the original formulation of
the problem.
So that's the goal.
And what I'd like to do is start
by motivating it with
the kind of practical thing
to get you thinking.
So here's the game,
Let's Make a Deal.
I'm going to put 4 LEGO
bricks in a bag.
OK.
LEGO bricks, you've seen
those probably.
Bag.
The LEGO bricks are
white or red.
There's only going to be 4, and
you're not going to know
how many of each there is.
Then you get to pull one LEGO
brick out, and if you pull a
red one out, I'll
give you 20$.
The hitch is you have to pay
me to play this game.
So the question is, how much are
you willing to pay me to
play the game?
So, I need a volunteer.
I need somebody to take 4 LEGOs
and not let me see, OK,
please, please.
I want you to put 4
LEGOs, only four.
They can be white or red.
If you have LEGOs in your
pockets that are a different
color, don't use them.
You're allowed to know what the
answer is but you're not
allowed to tell me, or them.
So OK well come over here.
So bag, LEGOs, hide,
put some number in.
Oh, no no no.
Wait, wait, wait.
Put them back, put them back.
I'm not supposed
to see either.
OK, I'll go way.
OK, 4.
OK, so we'll close
the bag, right?
And I'll call you back later,
but it'll be nearer
the end of the hour.
So here's 4 LEGOs, sort of
sounds like 4 LEGOs,
it's more than one.
OK, so how much would you
be willing to pay
me to play the game?
AUDIENCE: 5$.
PROFESSOR: 5$ --
Can I get more?
I want to make money.
Can I get a higher bid?
More than 5$..
AUDIENCE: $9.90.
PROFESSOR: How much?
PROFESSOR: $9.90, very
interesting.
Can I get more than $9.90?
AUDIENCE: $9.99 and a half.
PROFESSOR: $9.99 and a half?
Magic number.
AUDIENCE: 10$.
PROFESSOR: 10$.
Can I hear even a penny more?
A penny more?
AUDIENCE: I'll offer
a penny more.
You just have to
go to the bag.
PROFESSOR: I thought we were
being very careful and letting
them not know.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
Aren't you going to put 4 white
blocks in all the time?
PROFESSOR: I didn't do it.
That person did it.
It wasn't me.
I'm innocent.
I'm completely fair.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are we imagining that
you are equally as likely
to put any number
of blocks in?
So, are we able to say that
she's more likely
to put it all white?
Because that just changes
how you calculate it.
PROFESSOR: OK, that's an
interesting question.
We need a model of a person.
That's tricky.
OK, I have another idea.
Two more volunteers.
OK, volunteer, volunteer.
Here's the experiment one person
will hold the bag up
high, so that the other
person can't see it,
and the other person--
I didn't look in, notice I'm
being very careful, I'm very
honest, right?
Except for the X-ray vision,
which you don't know about.
Everything is completely fair.
And the little window in
the back you don't
know about that either.
So, one person holds it up so
the other person can't see in,
the other person grabs a LEGO
and pulls it out and lets
everybody see that LEGO.
It was intended to make
it hard to see in.
OK, red one.
OK, that's fine,
so we're done.
AUDIENCE: We each should
get $20, right?
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
This was a different
part of the bet.
No, no, no, no, no.
Thank you, thank you.
Now how much would you pay
me to play the game?
AUDIENCE: With that one out?
PROFESSOR: No, we'll
put that one back.
OK, so this one came
out, it was red.
Now without looking, I'm going
to stick it back in.
OK, so we pulled it out.
So what do we know?
We know there's at
least 1 red.
OK, now what are you willing
to pay to play the game?
AUDIENCE: 5$..
PROFESSOR: 5$..
Yes?
5$..
AUDIENCE: $4.99.
PROFESSOR: $4.99?
Wait a minute.
Should you be willing
to pay more or less?
I got it up to 10$.
Should you be willing to
pay more or less now?
AUDIENCE: More.
PROFESSOR: More, why?
The same.
More.
AUDIENCE: You're insured that
there's at least 1 red block.
PROFESSOR: I know that there's
at least 1, but didn't I know
that before?
No.
The person could have been e
that first person could have
loaded it, because I was
giving her a cut.
I didn't talk about
this before.
This is not a set-up.
So I want to vote.
How many people would give
me less than 10$?
I'm going to give you
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] first.
10 to 12.
Let's see, 13 to 15, 16
to 18, more than 18.
So how many people would
give me-- you're only
allowed to vote once.
Keep in mind that I'm more
likely to choose
you if you vote high.
Right?
Vote high.
So how many people would
give me less than
$10 to play the game?
A lot, I would say 20%.
How many people would give
me between $10 and $12?
A lot smaller, 5%.
How many people would give
me between $13 and $15?
Even smaller, 2%.
How many people would give
me between $16 and $18?
Wait, these numbers are not
going to add up to 100%.
OK, we'll learn the
theory for how to
normalize things in a minute.
OK, so we're down to about 1%.
How many people would give
me more than $18?
One person.
Thank you, thank you.
So that's 1 in 200 or 0.05%.
OK, so what I'd like to do now
is go through the theory
that's going to let us make a
precise calculation for how
much a rational person--
not to say
that you're not rational--
but how much a rational person
might be willing to pay.
So that was the set up, then
we'll do the theory, then
we'll come back at the end of
the hour and see how many
people I would have gypped--
made money, or whatever.
OK, so we're going to think
about probability.
And the first idea that
we need is set theory.
Because we're going to think
about experiments having
outcomes, and we're going
to talk about the
outcomes being an event.
An event is any describable
outcome from an experiment.
So for example, what if the
experiment were to flip 3
coins in sequence.
An event could be head,
head, head.
And you could talk about was the
outcome head, head, head.
The event could be head,
tail, ahead.
The event could be 1
head and 2 tails.
The event could be the first
toss was a head.
So the idea is there's sets that
we're rethinking about.
And we're going to think about
events as possible outcomes
being members of sets.
There's going to be a special
kind of event that we're
especially interested in, and
that is an atomic event.
By which we mean finest grain.
Finest grain is kind
of amorphous idea.
What it really means is for
the experiment at hand, it
doesn't seem to make sense to
try to slice the outcome into
two smaller units.
You keep slicing them down
until slicing them into a
smaller unit won't affect
the outcome.
So for example, in the coin toss
experiment, I might think
that there are 8
atomic events.
Head, head, head, head, head
tail, head, tail, head, head,
tail, tail, blah, blah, blah.
So I've ignored some things
like, it took 3 minutes to do
the first flip, and it took 2
minutes to do the second one.
Right?
That's the art of figuring out
what atomic units are.
So for the class of problems
that I'm thinking about, those
things can be ignored so
I'm not counting them.
But that's an art, that's
not really a science.
So you sort of have to use good
judgment when you try to
figure out what are the atomic
events for a particular
experiment.
Atomic events always have
several properties, they are
always mutually exclusive.
If I know the outcome was atomic
event 3, then I know
for sure that it was
not atomic event 4.
And you can see that these
events up here don't have
those properties, right?
So the first toss--
here's an event head, head,
head, which is not mutually
exclusive with the first
toss was a head.
So atomic that events have
to be mutually exclusive.
Furthermore, if you list all of
the atomic events, that set
has to be collectively
exhaustive.
Collectively exhaustive?
What buzz words?
OK, that means that you've
exhausted all possibilities
when you've accounted for the
collective behaviors of all
the atomic events.
And we have a very special name
for that because it comes
up over, and over,
and over again.
The set of atomic events, the
maximum set of atomic events,
is called the sample space.
So the first thing we need to
know when we're thinking about
probability theory, is
how to chunk outcomes
into a sample space.
Second thing we need to know are
the rules of probability.
These are the things that are
so absurdly simple, that
everybody who sees these
immediately comes to the
conclusion that probability
theory is trivial, they then
don't do anything until the next
exam, and then they don't
have a clue what we're asking.
Because it's subtle, it's more
subtle than you might think.
Here's the rules, probabilities
are real numbers
that are not negative.
Pretty easy.
Probabilities have the feature
that the probability of the
sample space is 1.
That's really just scaling.
That's really just telling me
how big all the numbers are.
So if I enumerate all the
possible atomic events, the
probability of having one of
those as the outcome of an
experiment, that probability
is 1.
Doesn't seem like I said much,
and I'm already 2/3 of the way
through the list.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't that just mean
that something happened?
PROFESSOR: Something
happened, yes.
And we are going to say that
this certain event has
probability 1.
All probabilities are real, all
probabilities are bigger
than 0, and the probability
of the certain event--
written here as the universe,
the sample space--
the probability of some
element in the
sample space is 1.
The only one that's terribly
interesting is additivity.
If the intersection between
A and B is empty, the
probability of the union is the
sum of the probabilities
of the individual events.
Astonishingly, I'm done.
And this doesn't alter the fact
that people are still, to
this day, doing fundamental
research
in probability theory.
There are many subjects in
probability theory, including
many highly advanced graduate
subjects, all of which derive
from these three rules.
It's absurd how un-intuitive
things can be given such
simple beginnings.
Just as an idea.
So you can prove all of the
interesting results from
probability theory--
you can prove all results from
probability theory with these
three rules, and here's
just one example.
If the intersection of A and B
were not empty, you can still
compute the probability of
the union, it's just more
complicated than if they were
empty, if the intersection
were empty.
Generally speaking, the
probability of the union of A
and B, is the probability of A
plus the probability of B,
minus the probability
of the intersection.
And you can sort of see why that
ought to be true, if you
think about a Venn diagram.
If you think about the odds of
having A in the universe--
the universe is the
sample space--
probability of having sum event
A, the probability of
having sum event B, the
probability of their
intersection.
If you were to just add the
probability of A and B, you
doubly count the intersection.
You don't want to double count
it, you want to count it once.
So you have to subtract
one off.
So that's sort of
what's going on.
OK, as I said the theory
is very simple.
But let's make sure that you've
got the basics first.
So experiment, I'm going to
roll a fair, 6-sided die.
And I'm going to count as the
outcome the number of dots on
the top surface, not
surprisingly.
Find the probability that the
roll is odd, and greater than
3 You have 10 seconds.
OK, 10 seconds are up.
What's the answer? (1),
(2), (3), (4) or (5)?
Raise your hands.
Excellent, wonderful.
The answer is (1).
The way I want you to think
about that is in terms of the
theory that we just generated
because it's useful for
developing the answers to more
complicated questions.
In terms of the theory, what we
will always do, the process
that always works, is enumerate
the sample space.
What's that mean?
That means identify all
of the atomic events.
The atomic events here are
the faces that show are
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Enumerate the sample space.
And then find the
event interest.
So here the event was
a compound event.
The result is odd and
greater than 3.
Odd, well that's 1, 3, 5, shown
by the check marks.
Bigger than 3, that's the
bottom 3 check marks.
If it's going to be both, then
you have to look where there's
overlap and that only happens
for the outcome 5.
Since there's only 1, and
so fair meant that these
probabilities were the same.
If you think through the
fundamental axioms of
probability, if they're equal,
they're all non-negative real
numbers, and they sum to 1,
then they are all 1/6.
So the answer is 1/6, right?
OK, that was easy.
The rule that is most
interesting for us, happens
not surprisingly to also be the
one that people have the
most trouble with.
Not excluding the people
who originally
invented the theory.
The theory goes back
to Laplace.
A bunch of people back then who
were absolutely brilliant
mathematicians, and still
it took a while to
formulate this rule.
It was formulated a
guy named Bayes.
Bayes' theorem gives us a way
to think about conditional
probability.
What if I tell you, in some
sample space, B happened?
How should you relabel the
probabilities to take that
into account?
Bayes' rule is trivial, it says
it if I know B happened,
what is the probability
that A occurs, given
that I know B happens?
And the rule is, you find
the probability of the
intersection.
AUDIENCE: How do you do that?
PROFESSOR: We'll do
some examples.
So we need to find the
probability of the
intersection, and then we have
to find the probability of B
occurring, and then
we normalize--
a word I used before, and that's
exactly what we need to
do to that distribution--
we normalize the intersection
by the probability of B.
That's an interesting rule.
It's the kind of thing we're
going to want to know about.
We're going to want to know--
OK, I'm a robot.
I'm in a space.
I don't know where I am.
I have some a priori probability
idea about where I
am, so I think I'm 1/20 likely
to be here, I'm 1/20 likely to
be there, et cetera,
et cetera.
And then I find out the sonars
told me that I'm 0.03 meters
-- no it can't be that small,
0.72 meters from a wall.
Well, how do I take into account
this new information
to update my probabilities
for where I might be?
That's what this rule
is good for.
So here's a picture.
The way to think about the rule
is if I condition on B,
if I tell you B happened, that's
equivalent to shrinking
the universe --
the universe U, the square.
That's everything
that can happen.
Inside the universe, there's
this event A and it does not
occupy the entire universe.
There is a fraction of outcomes
that belong logically
in not A. OK?
That's the part that's in U but
not in A. Similarly with
B. Similarly there's some
region, there's some part of
the universe where both A and
B occur, the intersection of
the two occurred.
So what Bayes' theorem says is,
if I tell you B occurred,
all this part of the universe
outside of B is irrelevant.
As far as you're concerned,
B's the new universe.
Notice that if B is the
new universe, then the
intersection--
which is the part where
A occurred--
is bigger after the conditioning
then it was
before the conditioning.
Before the conditioning the
universe was this big, now the
universe is this big.
The universe is smaller, so
this region of overlap
occupies a greater part
of the new universe.
Is that clear?
So when you condition, you're
really making the universe
smaller, And the relative
likelihood of things that are
still in the universe,
seem bigger.
So what's the conditional
probability of getting a die
roll greater than 3, given
that it was odd?
Calculate, you have
30 seconds.
This is three times harder.
OK, what's the probability of
getting a die roll greater
than 3, given that the
die role was odd?
Everybody raise your hands.
And it's a landslide,
the answer is (2).
You roughly do the same thing we
did before, except now the
math is incrementally
harder because you
have to do a divide.
So we think about the same two
events, the event that it is
odd and the event that it's
bigger than 3, and now we ask
the question.
If it were odd, what's the
likelihood that it's
greater than 3?
Before I did the conditioning,
what was the likelihood that
it was bigger than 3?
AUDIENCE: 1/6
PROFESSOR: Nope.
1/2.
So bigger than 3 is
4, 5, or 6 --
right?
There are 3 atomic
units there.
There are 6 atomic units
to start with.
They are equally likely.
So before I did the
conditioning, the event of
interest had a probability
of a 1/2.
After I do the conditioning, I
know that half of the possible
samples didn't happen.
The universe shrank.
Instead of having a sample space
with 6, I now have a
sample space with 3.
Similarly the probability
law changed.
So now the event of interest is
bigger than 3, but bigger
than 3 now only happens once.
So what I need to do is rescale
my probabilities.
Remember the scaling rule, one
of the fundamental properties
of probability.
The scaling rule said
the sum of the
probabilities must be 1.
After I've conditioned,
the sum of the
probabilities is a 1/2.
That's not good.
I've got to fix it.
So the way to think about Bayes'
rule is, if all I know
is it the universe
got smaller, how
should I redo the scaling?
Well if all I've told you is
that the answer is odd, then
there are three possibilities.
Before I told you that the
answer was odd, they were
equally likely.
After I tell you that they're
odd, has it changed the fact
that they're equally likely?
No.
They're still equally likely
even under that new condition.
I haven't changed their
individual probabilities.
So they started out equally
likely, they're still equally
likely, they just don't
sum to 1 anymore.
Bayes' rule says, make
them sum to 1.
OK, so the way I make this
sum, sum to one is
to divide by 1/2.
If you divide six by
1/2, you get 1/3.
Notice that the probability that
it's bigger than 3 went
from 1/2 to a 1/3.
It got smaller.
It could have gone either way.
So, think about what happens
when the world shrinks, when
the universe gets
smaller, when I
tell you that B happened.
Well when I tell you that B
happened, then I ask you
whether A happened, here I'm
showing a picture that in the
original universe A and
B sort of covered the
same amount of area.
By which I mean, they're
about equally likely.
Before I did the conditioning,
the probability of A was about
the same size as the probability
of B. What happens
when I condition?
Well, when I condition now the
universe is B. But notice the
way I've drawn them, there's
very little overlap.
So now when I condition on B,
the odds that I'm in A seems
to have got smaller.
Rather than being of equal
probability, as I show here,
after the conditioning the
relative likelihood of being
event A is smaller than
it used to be.
But that's entirely because of
the way I rigged the circles.
I could have rigged the circles
to have a large amount
of overlap.
Then when I condition, it
seems as though it's
relatively more likely that
I'm in the event A. That's
what we mean by the
conditioning.
The conditioning can give you
un-intuitive insight.
Because when you condition,
probabilities can get bigger
or littler.
And that's something that sort
of at a gut level, we all have
trouble dealing with.
OK, so that's the fundamental
ideas, right?
We've talked about events.
Three axioms of probability that
are completely trivial.
One, not quite so trivial rule,
which is Bayes' rule.
In order to apply it, there's
two more things we need to
talk about.
The first is, notation.
We could do the entire rest of
the course using the notation
that I showed so far, drawing
circles on the blackboard, it
would work.
It would not be very
convenient.
So to better take advantage of
math, which is a very concise
way to write things down, we
will define a new notion which
is a random variable.
Random variable is just like a
variable, except shockingly,
it's random.
So where we would normally
think about a variable
represents a number, a random
variable represents a
distribution.
So we could, for example in the
die rolling case, we could
say the sample space has 6
atomic events, and I could
think about it as 6 circles.
Circles wouldn't pack
all that well.
6 squares inside the
universe, right?
Because they are mutually
exclusive, and collectively
exhaustive, so if I started with
a universal that looked
like that, I would have this one
would be the probability
that the number of dots was 1,
2, 3, it has to fill up by the
time I've put 6 of
them in there.
And they have to not overlap.
A more convenient notation is
to say, OK, let's let X
represent that outcome.
So I can label the
events with math.
I can say, there's the event X
equals 1, the event X equals
2, the event X equals 3, and it
just makes it much easier
to write down the possibilities,
then to try to
draw pictures with Venn
diagrams all the time.
So all we're doing here is
introducing a mathematical
representation for the same
thing we talked about before.
But among the things that
you can do, after you've
formalized this, so you can have
a random variable then
it's a very small jump
to say you can have a
multi-dimensional
random variable.
Let's just for example
have a 2-space.
X and Y, for example.
So now we can talk very
conveniently about situations
that factor.
So, for example when I think
about flipping 3 coins, I can
think about that as a
multivariate random variable
in three dimensions.
One dimension represents the
outcome of the first die--
the first coin toss.
Another dimension is the
second, the third
dimension is the third.
So there is a very convenient
way of talking about it, and
we have a more concise
notation.
We say, OK let V be the outcome
of the first die roll,
or whatever.
Let W be the second one, and
then we can think about the
joint probability distribution,
in terms of the
multi-dimensional
random variable.
So we have the random variable
defined by V and W. We will
generally to try to make things
easy for you to know
what we're trying to talk about,
we'll try to remember
to capitalize things when we're
talking about random
variables, and then we'll use
the small numbers to talk
about events.
So this notation would represent
the probability that
V took on the value little
v, and W took on the
value little w.
We'll see examples of
this in a minute.
So the idea is-- you don't need
to do this, it's just a
convenient notation
to write more
complicated things concisely.
Now a concept that's very easy
to talk about, now we have
random variables, is reducing
dimensionality.
And in fact, we will
constantly reduce
dimensionality of complicated
problems that are represented
by multiple dimensions, to
smaller dimensional problems.
And we'll talk about two
ways of doing that.
The first is what we will
call marginalizing.
Marginalizing means, I don't
care what happened in the
other dimensions.
So if I have a probability
rule that told me, for
example, about the outcome of
one toss a fair die, and a
second toss of a fair die, and
if I tell you the joint
probability space
for that, right?
So I would have 6 outcomes on
one dimension, 6 outcomes on
another dimension, let's say
they're all equally likely.
I have 36 points altogether, if
they're all equally likely,
then my probability law is
a joint distribution.
The joint distribution has 32
non-zero points and each point
has height of.
I said the right thing, right.
36 is what I meant to say.
My brain is telling me that I
might not have said that.
I meant 36.
So if I have 36 equally likely
events, how high is each one?
1/36.
OK, so the joint probability
space for two tosses of a fair
6-sided die, is this
6-by-6 space.
And I may be interested
in marginalizing.
Marginalizing would mean,
I don't care what
the second one was.
OK well, how do you infer the
rule for the first one from
the joint, if I don't care what
the second one was, well
you sum out the second.
So if I have this 2-space
that represented the
first and the second.
So, say its X and
Y, for example.
So, I've got 6 points that
represent 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
And then 6 this way, that sort
of thing, except now I have to
draw in tediously all of
the others, right?
So you get the idea.
Each one of the X's represents a
point with probability 1/36,
and imagine direction that
they're all in straight lines.
Now if I didn't care what is
the second one, how would I
find the rule for the first one,
well I just sum over the
second one.
So, say I'm only interested in
what happened in the first
one, well I would describe all
of the probabilities here to
that point.
I would sum out the one that
I don't care about.
That's obvious, right?
Because if I marginalized these
X's that all represent
the number 1/36 have to turn
into a single dimension axis,
which is just X, and they have
to be 6 numbers that
are each how high?
1/6, right?
So the way I get 6 numbers
that are each 1/6, when I
started with 36 numbers that
were each 1/36 is use sum.
OK, so that's called
marginalization.
The other thing that I
can do is condition.
I can tell you something about
the sample space and ask you
to figure out a conditional
probability.
So I might tell you what's the
probability rule for Y
conditioned on the first
one being 3?
OK.
Mathematically that's a
different problem, that's a
re-scale problem, because
that's Bayes' rule.
So generally if I carved out by
conditioning some fraction
of the sample space, the way
you would compute the new
probabilities would
be to re-scale.
So there's two operations
that we will do.
We will marginalize, which
means summing out.
And we will condition,
which means re-scale.
OK.
So give some practice
at that, let's think
about a tangible problem.
Example, prevalence and
testing for AIDS.
Consider the effectiveness
of a test for AIDS.
This is real data.
Data from the United States.
So imagine that we take a
population, representative of
the population in the United
States, and classify every
individual as having AIDS or
not, and being diagnosed
according to some test as
positive or negative.
OK, two dimensional.
The two dimensions are
what was the value of
AIDS, true or false?
And what's the value of the
test, positive or negative?
So we've divided the population
into four pieces.
And by using the idea of
relative frequency, I've
written probabilities here.
So what's the probability of
choosing by random choice an
individual that has AIDS
and tested positive.
OK, so that's 0,003648,
et cetera.
So I've divided the population
into four groups.
Multidimensional,
multidimensional random variable.
OK.
The question is, what's the
probability that the test is
positive given that the
subject has AIDS?
I want to know how
good the test is.
So the first question I'm going
to ask is, given that
the person has AIDS what's the
probability that the test
gives a true answer?
You've got 60 seconds.
This is harder.
Some people don't think
it's harder.
So what's the probability that
the test is positive, given
that the subject has AIDS?
Is it bigger than 90%?
Between 50% and 90%?
Less than 50%?
Or you can't tell
from the data?
Everybody vote, and the answer
is 100% correct.
Wonderful.
So let me make it harder.
Is it between 90% and 95%?
Or between 95% and a 100%?
AUDIENCE: 95% and a 100%
PROFESSOR: 95%.
Is it between 95% and 97%,
or 97% and 100%?
OK, sorry.
This is called marginalization.
I told you something about the
population that lets you
eliminate some of the numbers.
So if I told you that the person
has AIDS, then I know
I'm in the first column.
That's marginalization.
I gave you new information.
I'm saying the other cases
didn't happen.
I've shrunk the universe, it
used to have 4 groups of
people, now it has 2 groups of
people, I used Bayes' rule.
I need to re-scale the numbers
so that they add to 1.
So these 2 numbers, the only 2
possibilities that can occur--
after I've done the
conditioning, no
longer add to 1.
I've got to make
them add to 1.
I do that by dividing by the
probability of the event that
I'm using to normalize.
So the sum of these two
probabilities is something,
whatever it is 0.003700.
So I divide each of those
probabilities by that sum,
that's just Bayes' rule.
And I find out that the answer
is the probability that the
test is positive--
given that person has AIDS, the
probability that the test
is positive is 0.986.
Good test?
98%.
I won't say that.
98%. is a good test right?
Not that today is an appropriate
day to talk about
the outcomes of tests and 98%.
But, I won't mention that.
OK, so good test.
The accuracy of the test
is greater than 98%.
Quite good.
New question.
What's the probability that
the subject has AIDS given
that the test is positive?
Everybody vote. (1),
(2), (3), (4).
Looks 100%.
OK, the answer is
less than 50%.
Why is that?
Well that's another
marginalization problem, but
now we're marginalizing on
a different population.
This is how you can go awry
thinking about probability.
The 2 numbers seem kind
of contradictory.
Here I'm saying that the test
came out positive and I'm
asking does the subject
have AIDS.
It's still marginalization.
I'm still throwing away 2 of the
conditions, two fractions
of the population, I'm only
thinking about 2.
I still have to normalize so
that the sums come out 1, but
the numbers are different.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Because my brain's
not working.
OK, I've been saying
marginalization and I meant
uniformly, over the last five
minutes, to be saying
conditioning.
OK, so I skipped breakfast this
morning, my blood sugar
is low, sorry.
Thank you very much.
I should have been saying
conditioning.
Sorry.
OK, so backing up.
OK I conditioned on the fact
that the person had AIDS, and
then I conditioned on
the fact that the
test came up positive.
In both cases I was
conditioning.
doing Bayes' rule.
Please ignore the person
who can't connect his
brain to his mouth.
So, here because the
conditioning event has a very
different set of numbers from
these numbers, the relative
likelihood that the subject
has AIDS is small.
So even though the test is very
effective in identifying
cases that are known to be true,
it is not very effective
in taking a random person from
the population and saying the
test was positive,
you have it.
OK, those are very different
things and the probability
theory gives us a way
to say exactly how
different those are.
Why are they so different?
The reason they're different
is that other word.
Because the marginal
probabilities are so different.
And that is because the
population is skewed.
So the fact that the test came
out positive, is offset at
least somewhat by the skew
in the population.
So the point here is actually
marginalizing.
If I think about how many people
in the population have
AIDS, that means I'm summing
on the columns, rather than
conditioning.
And what you see is a very
skewed population.
And that's the reason you can't
conclude from the test,
whether or not this particular
subject has the disease or not
because the population
is so skewed.
So this was intended to be an
example of conditioning versus
marginalization and how you
think about that in a
multi-dimensional
random variable.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Don't you sum
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] in order to
do Bayes' rule?
PROFESSOR: In order to condition
on has AIDS, you
need to sum has AIDS.
And then you use that number.
Yes?
That's right.
AUDIENCE: So how are
they different?
PROFESSOR: One of them has a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] and the other
one doesn't.
So when we did Bayes' rule, we
did the marginalization here,
but then we use that summed
number to normalize the
individual probabilities by
scaling, by dividing.
So that the new sum, over
the new smaller sample
space is still one.
So your point 's right.
So regardless of whether we're
conditioning or marginalizing,
we still end up computing
the marginals.
it's just that in one case were
done, and in the other
case we use that marginal
to re-scale OK?
So I said, we could just use
set theory and we're done.
We'll in fact use
random variables
because it's simpler.
That's one of the two other
things we need to do which are
non-essential, it just makes
our life easier.
And the other non-essential
thing that we will do is
represent it in some sort
of a Python structure.
So we would like to be able
to conveniently represent
probabilities in Python.
The way we'll do that, is a
little obscure the first time
you look at it.
But again, once you've done
it a few times it's a very
natural way of doing
it, otherwise we
wouldn't do it this way.
How are we going to represent
probability laws in Python?
The way we'll do it, since the
labels for random variables
can be lots of different
things-- so for example, the
label in the previous one was
in the case of the subject
having AIDS or not, the label
was true or false.
The label for the test was
positive or negative.
So in order to allow you to
give symbolic and human
meaningful names to events we
will use a dictionary as the
fundamental way of associating
probabilities with events.
So, we'll represent
a probability
distribution by a class--
what a surprise, by
a Python class--
that we will call DDist which
means discrete distribution.
DDists want to associate the
name of an atomic event which
we will let you use any string,
or in fact any--
I should generalize that.
You can use any Python data
structure to identify an
atomic event.
And then we will associate
that using a Python
dictionary, with the
probability.
So what we will do when you
instantiate a new discrete
distribution, you will-- the
instantiation rule, you must
call it with a dictionary.
A dictionary is a thing in
Python that associates one
thing with another thing, I'll
give an example in a minute.
And the utility of this is that
you'll be able to use as
your atomic event a string, like
true or false, a string
like positive or negative, or
something more complicated
like a tuple.
And I'll show you an example of
where you would want to do
that in just a second.
So the idea is going to be
you establish a discrete
distribution by the unique
method called the dictionary.
The dictionary is just a list
of keys which tell you which
event that you're trying to
name the probability of.
Associated with a number,
and that number is the
probability.
And this shows you that
there's one extremely
interesting method, which
is the Prob method.
The idea is that Prob will
tell you what is the
probability associated
with that key.
If it doesn't find the key in
the dictionary, I'll tell you
the answer is 0.
We do that for a specific reason
too, because a lot of
the probability spaces that we
will talk about, have lots of
0's in them.
So instead of having to
enumerate all of the cases
that are 0 we will assume that
if you didn't tell us a
probability, the answer was 0.
OK so this is the idea.
I could say use the disk module
in lib 601 to create
the outcome of a coin
toss experiment.
And I have a syntax error.
This should have had
a squiggle brace.
A dictionary is something
that in Python--
So I should have said something
like this--
dist.DDist of squiggle.
Sorry about that, that should've
said squiggle, I'll
fix it and put the answer
on the website.
Head should be associated with
the probability 0.5 and tail
should be associated with
the probability 0.5.
End of dictionary,
end of call.
Sorry, I missed the squiggle.
Actually what happened was,
I put the squiggle in
and LaTeX ate it.
Because that's the
LaTeX, anyway.
It's sort of my fault.
The dog ate my homework.
LaTeX ate my squiggle, it's
sort of the same thing.
So having defined a
distribution, then I can ask
what's the probability
of the event head?
The answer is a half.
The probability of event tail?
The probability of event H?
There is no H. The answer 0.
That's what I meant
by sparsity.
If I didn't tell you what the
probability is, we assume the
answer is 0.
Conditional probabilities are
a little more obscure.
What's the conditional
probability that the test
gives me some outcome given that
I tell you the status of
whether the patient has,
or doesn't have AIDS?
OK, well conditionals--
you're going to have to tell
me which case I want to
condition on.
So in order for me to tell you
the right probability law you
have to tell me does the person
have AIDS or not.
So that becomes an argument.
So we're going to represent
conditional probabilities as
procedures.
That's a little weird.
So the input to the procedure,
specifies the condition.
So if I want to call the
procedure and find out what's
the distribution for the
tests, given that
the person has AIDS?
Then I would call, test
given AIDS of true.
So if AIDS is true, return this
DDist, otherwise return
this DDist.
So it's a little bizarre but
think about what it has to do.
If I want to specify a
conditional probability, I
have to tell you an answer.
And that's what the
parameter is for.
So the way that would work is
illustrated here having
defined this as the conditional
distribution I
could call it by saying what is
the distribution on tests
given that AIDS was true?
And the answer to that
is the DDist.
Or if I had that DDist, which
would be this phrase, I could
say what's then the probability
in that new
distribution that the
answer is negative?
Then I would look up the dot
prob method within the
resulting conditional
distribution, and look up the
condition negative.
And finally the way that I
would think about a joint
probability distribution,
is to use a tuple.
Joint probability distributions
are
multi-dimensional, tuples
are multi-dimensional.
So for example, if I wanted
to represent this
multi-dimensional data,
I might have the joint
distribution of AIDS
and tests.
OK that's a 2-by-2.
AIDS can take on 2 different
values, true or false.
And tests can take
on 2 different
values, positive or negative.
So there's 4 cases.
The way I would specify a joint
distribution would be
create a joint distribution
starting with the marginal
distribution for AIDS and then
using Bayes' rule tell me the
two different conditional
probabilities given AIDS.
And that then will create a new
joint distribution that
whose DDist is a tuple.
So in this new joint
distribution, AIDS and tests,
if AIDS is false, and
test is negative--
so false negative
is this number--
the probability associated with
tuple is that number.
Is that clear?
So I'm going to construct
joint distributions by
thinking about conditional
probabilities.
So I have a simple distributions
which are
defined with dictionaries.
I have conditional probabilities
which are
defined by procedures.
And I have joint probabilities
which are defined by tuples.
OK, so that's the Python magic
that we will use and a lot of
the exercises for Week 10 have
to do with getting that
nomenclature straight.
It's a little confusing at
first, I assure you that by
the time you've practiced
with it, it is
a reasonable notation.
It just takes a little bit of
practice to get onto it, much
like other notations.
OK where are we going
with this?
What we would like to do is
solve that problem that I
showed at the beginning
of the hour.
So we would like to know things
like, where am I?
So the kind of thing that we're
going to do is think
about where am I based on my
current velocity and where I
think I am, odometry--
which is uncertain,
it's unreliable--
versus for example where
I think I am
based on noisy sensors.
OK so that's like two
independent noisy things.
Right?
The odometry you can't
completely rely on it.
You've probably run
into that by now.
The sonars are not completely
reliable.
So there are two kinds
of noisy things.
How do you optimally
combine them?
That's where we're heading.
So the idea is going to be
here I am, I think I'm a
robot, I think I'm heading
toward a wall, I'd like to
know where am I.
So the kinds of data that we're
going to look at are
things like, I think I know
where I started out.
Now my thinking could
be pretty vague.
It could be, I have no clue so
I'm going to assume that I'm
equally likely anywhere
in space.
So I have a small probability
of being many places.
That just means that my initial
distribution is very broad.
But then I will define where
I think I am by taking into
account where I think I will
be after my next step.
So I think I'm moving
at some speed.
If I were here, and if
I'm going at some
speed I'll be there.
So we will formalize that by
thinking about a transition.
I think that if I am here at
time T, I will be there at
time T plus 1.
And I'll also think about, what
do I think the sonars
should've told me.
If I think I'm here, what would
the sonars have said?
And we'll use those as a way
to work backwards in
probability, use Bayes' rule.
To say, I have a noisy idea
about where I will be if I
started there.
I have a noisy idea of what the
sonars would have said, if
I started there.
But I don't know where
I started.
Where did I start?
That's the way we're going to
use the probability theory.
So for example, if I thought I
was here and if I thought I
was going ahead 2 units in
space per unit in time, I
would think that the
next time I'm here.
But since I'm not quite sure
where I was maybe I'll be
there, and maybe I'll be there,
but there's very little
chance that I'll be there.
That's what I mean by
a transition model.
It's a probabilistic way of
describing the difference
between where I start and where
I finish in one step.
Similarly, we'll think about
an observation model.
If I think I'm here,
what do I think the
sonars would have said.
Well I think I've got some
distribution that it's very
likely that they'll give me the
right answer, but it might
be a little short it
might be a long.
Maybe it'll make
a bigger error.
So I'll think about
two things.
Where do I think I will be
based on how I'm going?
And where do I think I'll be
based on my observations?
And then we'll try to formalize
that into a
structure that gives me a better
idea of where I am.
That's the point of the
exercises next week when we
won't have a lecture.
So this week we're going to
learn how to do some very
simple ideas with modelling
probabilities.
With thinking about these
kinds of distributions.
And the idea next week then is
going to be incorporating it
into a structure that will let
us figure out where the robot
is in some sort of
an optimal sense.
So thinking about optimal --
let's come back to the
original question.
How much would you pay
me to play the game?
OK, we had some votes.
They didn't add up to 1.
What should I do to make
them add up to 1?
Divide by the sum.
Right?
Look at all of you know
already, right?
So you now know all this great
probability theory.
So the question is can we use
probability theory to come up
with a rational way of thinking
how much it's worth?
Most of you thought that it's
worth less than 10$.
OK, so how do we think
about this?
How do we use the theory that
we just generated to come up
with a rational decision about
how much that's worth?
OK, thinking about the bet
quantitatively, what we're
going to try to do
is think about it
with probability theory.
There are 5 possibilities
inside the bag.
Originally there could have been
4 white, or 3 white and 1
red, or 2 and 2, or 1
and 3, or 0 and 4.
That was the original case.
You didn't know.
I didn't know.
They were thrown into
the bag over here.
We didn't know.
How much would that game--
how much should you be willing
to pay to play that game?
Someone asked how many white
ones and how many red ones did
the person put in the bag?
I don't have a clue, right?
We need a model for
the person.
Since I don't have a clue, one
very common strategy is to say
all these things I know nothing
about let's just
assume they're all
equally likely.
So that's called maximum
likelihood, when you do that.
There's other possible
strategies.
I'll use the maximum likelihood
idea just
because it's easy.
So I have no idea.
Let's just assume that here's
all of the conditions that
could have happened.
The number of red that are in
the bag could have been 0, 1,
2, 3, or 4.
I have no idea how the
person chose the
number of LEGO parts.
So I'll assume that each of
those cases is 1/5 likely,
since there's 5 cases.
OK now I'll think about what's
my expected value of the
amount of money that I'll make
if the random variable S,
which is the number of red
things that are in the bag was
s which is either 0,
1, 2, 3, or 4.
OK, if there are 0, how much
money do you expect to make?
None.
If there are 4 reds, how
much money would
you expect to make?
$20 If there are 2 reds, you
would expect to make 10 $.
Everybody see that.
I'm trying to think through a
logical sequence of steps for
thinking about how much is it
worth to play the game.
So this is the amount of money
that you would expect given
that the number of red in the
bag, which you don't know,
were 0, 1, 2, 3, or 4.
That's this row.
What's the probability, what's
the expected value of the
amount of money you would
get., and that happens?
Well I have to use
Bayes' rule.
What I need to do is I have to
take this probability times
that amount to get that
dollar value.
So over here, in the event that
there are 4 reds in the
bag, I'm expecting to get $20
but that's only 1/5 likely.
Right?
Because there don't have to
be 4 reds in the bag.
So I multiply the 1/5 times
the $20, and I get 4$.
So my expected outcome
for this trial is 4$.
Here, I'm expecting to make 10$
if I knew that there was 2
reds in the bag.
But I don't know that there's
2 reds in the bag, there's a
1/5 probability there's
2 reds in the bag.
So 1/5 of my expected amount of
money which is 10$ is 2$.
So then in order to figure out
my expected amount money I
just add these all up,
marginalizing.
And I get the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
4 plus 3 is 7 plus 2
is 9 plus 1 is 10.
So this theory says it if I can
regard the person who put
the LEGOs in the bag as being
completely random, I should
expect to make 10$ on
the experiment.
So that means you should
be willing to pay 10$.
Because on average, you'll
get back 10$.
If you wanted to make a
profit you ought to be
willing to pay 9$.
Right?
Because then you would pay
9$ expecting to get 10$.
If you really would like
to make a loss, right?
Then you should pay $11.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why do we
assume that these
events are equally likely?
PROFESSOR: Completely
arbitrary.
So there's theories, more
advanced theories, for how you
would make that choice.
So for example if in your head
you thought that the person
just took a large collection of
LEGO parts and reached in,
then you would think that the
number of red and white might
depend on the number that
started out in the bin.
But I don't think that's
probably true, right.
The person was probably looking
at them and saying, oh
throw in one red, through
in one white.
So you need a theory for doing
that, and I'm saying that in
the absence of any other
information let me assume that
those are equally likely and
see what the consequence of
that would be.
The consequence of assuming that
is that I should expect
to get 10 $ back.
What happens if you
pull out a red?
As we did.
How does that affect things?
Well it increases
the bottom line.
I start out again with the
assumption that all 5 cases
are equally likely.
Now I have to ask the case, how
likely is it that the one
that we pulled out was red?
Well it's not very likely that
the one that I pulled out was
red, if they were all white.
The probability of that
happening is 0.
What's the probability if there
were 2 that the person
pulled out a red?
Well 2 of them were red, 2 of
them were white, 2 out of 4
cases would have showed this
case of pulling out a red.
So this line then tells
me how likely is it
that the red was pulled.
OK.
Then what I want to do is
think about what's the
probability that I pulled
out a red, and there was
0, 1, 2, 3, or 4.
So I multiply 1/5 times 0/40,
0/20, 1/5 times 1/4 to get
1/20, 1/5 times 2/4
you get 2/20.
So those are probabilities
of each
individual event happening.
But they don't sum to 1.
So then the next step I have
to make them sum to 1.
So the sum of these is a 1/2.
So I make them sum
to one this way.
So now what's happened is it's
relatively more likely 4 out
of 10, that this case happened,
than that case.
I know for sure, for example,
that there's not 4 whites.
The probability of
4 whites is 0--
0 out of 10
So what I've done is I've skewed
the distribution toward
more red by learning that
there's at least 1, I now know
that I know additional
information.
These were not equally likely.
In fact, the ones with
more red were
relatively more likely.
So if I compute this probability
times that
expected amount, I now get a
much bigger answer for the
high number of reds.
So I still get 0 just like I
did before for this case,
because there's no
reds in the bag.
But now it's much more likely
that they're all red, because
I know there was
at least 1 red.
And then the answer
comes out $15.
So my overall assessment,
don't go to Vegas.
You could have made a lot more
money by offering $13.
Because on average,
you should've
expected to make $15.
OK, so what I wanted to do by
this example is go through a
specific example of how you can
speak quantitatively about
things that are uncertain.
And that's the theme for
the rest of the course.